welcome to Google developers life you're
on our fourth episode of the office
hours for Udacity CS 256 mobile web
development I'm here in the studio this
week only with Sean Bennett's the course
architect from Udacity Chris is out in
Maui yeah lucky that's a rough life yeah
so we're here in spirit that's right
he's out there scuba diving yeah so we
have some great questions and let's dive
right into them yeah so the first
question is from Matthias in Los Angeles
actually it's a two-part question so
since the mobile web is practically
changing everyday how do you not see
Udacity making another mobile web
development course in a matter of a
couple of months so that part I think
well there are two parts to them of
course
we are hard at work at defining what our
next course should be we don't have any
details quite yet but I think we did
take the approach that we use a lot of
the fundamentals in this course so we
don't expect that this course will
change that much some areas obviously
are subject to change and will need to
be redone responsive images that comes
to mind yeah exactly that's evolving
everyday that's a very cutting edge yeah
but the basic principles I would say
still very much apply I think a good
percentage like maybe I don't know 80 75
80 percent is really going to be there
these are tried and through principles
of the web development and and will
apply for a long time but that said I
think yes we are already thinking of the
next course and right it breaks through
the second point how much coffee does an
average Google Chrome developer drink so
well I think maybe you can yeah we did
it here on the table yeah we were
thinking about your question most of the
night so
coffee aficionados as well shot often
meet in San Francisco at one of our
favorite coffee oh yeah coffee bars yeah
they haven't done that we should do that
yeah talking about the the first
question again I think a lot of the the
next courses we would do on mobile web
development are actually building off
the fundamentals the right we've talked
about here so diving more into specific
things you can do with with you know
been the various device sensors for
instance yeah I mean there's a lot of
like individual use cases that a general
course doesn't really need to talk about
but is very interesting web sockets or
something like that would be something
that will be really useful server so
yeah yeah there's a lot to do about
students that we need to do another 58
courses so we have we have idea
hopefully should be able to share them
pretty soon yeah so Javy in Spain I was
asking you a couple of great questions
so regarding the power consumption of
the phone antenna one of the lessons
explains the different states of it
depending on the request being made what
is the behavior with a web socket and
server sent events are they power-hungry
in keeping the antenna on so I think
it's a great question
as Sean said we are definitely overdue
of creating a some server-side logic
parts of the course mm-hmm of a new
course in the future so so in essence
Java if you create a plain WebSocket
connection and you were not to send any
data over it then you would not be using
every connection would be completely
idle therefore not using any power so
what where gets interesting is WebSocket
you really need to think of sort of a
server side and a client side component
and they need to sort of speak to each
other and so in between there's the
network there are proxy servers there's
lots of other stuff that that gets in
the middle of your end-to-end connection
and that's where you get into things
like keepalive messages that need to be
sent for example
mobile network carriers they often
timeout between five and 15 minutes of
idle connection so you need to make sure
that that that stays open
yeah but then the the the problem is
that developers say oh we're doing these
keep it lives anyway let's just throw a
bunch of other right holes over the wire
let's just check for new data and that's
where it gets sort of taken out of place
so a couple of good things to check on
and I posted these in already yesterday
I posted some links and this morning
actually just added on our link so added
some links in the moderator so check
that out javi there are a couple of
great things so there's an AT&T tool
that allows you to test you know had how
much bandwidth is being used and that's
a great external tool that you can use
to to do some testing yourself also a
must-read is a book from my colleague
ilya grigorik
high-performance browser networking
there's a whole chapter on how to
eliminate polling mm-hm and I think
that's really you have to take a step
back again as well and say all right
you're using a WebSocket so supposedly
you're doing that for some sort of real
time data so what's the alternative
right the alternative is a checks
polling that's gonna be far worse worse
not just in terms of battery power but
also in data consumption because you
have old overhead that comes with that
the a CDP requests and that are being
set up and torn down so lots of problems
there I think you're definitely on the
right track with the WebSocket and
server sent events and then it's also a
matter of like doing it right and check
out helia in-depth chapter on that than
you know I would actually say just check
out the book period yeah yeah I'm for
sure a lot of a lot of web developers
don't actually know as much as they
should about the underlying network yeah
and how it works and Billy does a
fantastic job of laying the entire thing
out very clearly
great alright so another question from
javi I don't think it's possible right
now but are there plans to mock other
devices sensors like camera video mic so
I'm not aware of that I think the
majority of the stuff that's being that
you can mock like geolocation is stuff
that when you're developing on a desktop
you just don't have access to easily
yeah I think it's pretty common to have
a camera these days I mean yeah that
that's changed of course from a few
years ago maybe you might not but right
right so I think but geolocation would
definitely be something that you would
have easily access to it at mobile if I
I think anything that you feel would
make sense as a feature yeah
just file a bug so in chrome you can do
that them see our bug all the other
browsers that have their own ways to
file enhancement requests rather than
box it's not a bug of course myths right
but but you can definitely I think and
actually coming to one of your other
questions mm-hmm oh yeah let me just
that was which I love this yeah this was
a really cool idea from javi about
mocking the access to the devices GPS
sensor the chrome dev tools offer the
ability to overwrite location with a
fixed location right is there a way to
mock an actual route with multiple GPS
readings right I think it's bro yeah
that's an awesome idea you should file
this and go to see our bug the chrome
bug tracker for chromium with us in
chromium's or would this be in the dev
tools team specifically no well it's so
just all the same the same but then I
will be triaged accordingly right oh
okay yeah I think that's actually when I
read it I thought wow that's totally
something that should be done yeah so
great great idea yeah I'll definitely be
talking internally a little bit more
about that as well hmm this shouldn't
ultimately be too hard no I wouldn't
think so I mean work you could make it
really really nice if you had just you
know the ability to drought or out or
something but even just having like a
list of even the GPS points or like a
start end and then figure it out from
there we would already be really awesome
yeah
so we had to get some data from the
Google Maps yeah exact Direction is API
right yeah that's actually really cool
um maybe you could set a speed oh yeah
I'd be I'd be interested yeah so this is
for anyone that doesn't is not aware of
it so there's a navigator sort of
there's a two ways to get geolocation so
you can do a one-shot location or it is
watch position mm-hmm which gives you
constant feedback as to where you are so
that's something you currently they
can't mock all right so good idea all
right
uh Craig from Maine what are your
recommendations for automated testing
tools to use to do integration testing
of mobile web apps
what about unit testing of JavaScript
and CSS is there such a thing yes for
overall automated testing my favorite
test Runner is karma by far I don't
think anything really else really comes
close it gives you the ability to
automatically open up a browser or run
it run it in phantom JS for instance if
you want to do a headless testing it's a
fantastic test runner and it supports
just about any testing framework that
you would want to use personally I
really like karma with mocha mocha is an
actual unit testing framework okay mocha
yes and it's it's fantastic that's the
one we use we used to use jasmine which
is also really good we just ended up
liking mocha a little bit better chai
for individual like be BDD like a
behavior driven development testing is
really good for mocking stuff what I've
generally used is sign-on I don't
actually know if that's how you
pronounce it but it's really good for
mocking and spying on various methods
and objects does does this very well
for overall use testing and browser
testing selenium is a good one I would
say that's really nice I think that's
most of the stack we use at Udacity
actually I don't know do you have an any
other recommendations that's about right
mm-hmm I mean all of those together and
you get a pretty good I would say
testing infrastructure and coverage so I
would recommend using all those tools
they all have really good documentation
I think is the main reason we went with
just about all of those there are other
options out there but the documentation
for all of those is really nice in my
opinion breath another question from
Craig how would you handle input
validation and output escaping of data
input by users to prevent the cross-site
scripting attacks question do it on the
server yeah so actually does bring up a
good yeah so a lot of the input features
right well of the the nice form
functionality in html5 really only gives
you sort of a client-side convenience
yeah you still need to do all of the
testing on the server so even if you
have let's say type equals email mm-hmm
and you send that to the server using to
form even if you have a pattern that it
has to conform to right you know can't
be guaranteed because supposedly anyone
could bypass like you could bypass even
the browser yeah and create some sort of
client that's sense
yeah directly to server so right easily
the server needs to be set up to be very
careful about any data that is coming in
yeah and it needs to most most
frameworks that you're going to run
server-side have this basically built in
at this point this is you can you can
turn it off but a most modern frameworks
where I do it by default and you have to
explicitly turn it off which you
shouldn't do well it's not something you
want to reinvent all right exactly this
is something that you can easily get
wrong so I I would just whatever
framework you end up going with Iowa
actually check what they're escaping
policy is if it's not automatically
turned on then read their documentation
on how to turn it on is doing this
yourself is it's like crypto doing it
yourself is a bad idea
that's hard it's easy to get wrong and
it's very painful when you do get it
wrong cool
so Luke in Honolulu well hmm maybe he
should just go yeah please
hop hop one island Maui and ask your
question Chris on the bed okay I'm gonna
come back here well take it we'll take a
stab at it can you give a newbie
description of the tech stack used in
developing the conference app what did
use and why for example node compost
grunt Bower yeoman App Engine and so on
okay you know yeah description of it
yeah sure so um actually let's just
start at yeoman because that's what sets
all of this up so if you don't know
yeoman is basically a scaffolding tool
and it's fantastic it you know you tell
it what kind of application you want to
run or build if it's just a bare web app
if it's just for example a polymer
application or a rails app or angular
you know what whatever you happen to be
building out and it'll ask you a bunch
of questions about different things you
want to include if you want to use
bootstrap or not it's actually really
well done it's really uh well-maintained
to it's actively developed all the time
and they're constantly adding new
features and tweaking tweaking the
scaffolding essentially and what that'll
do is it'll set up a bear index file and
a code structure a folder structure
essentially and for organiz organized
along your code it'll also set up a
build step and using grunt I think
mostly using grunt right now I though I
think they're working with getting gulp
setup to of course but so it'll set up
this build step where you can for
example minify all of your JavaScript or
deal with any CSS preprocessors that you
might have
anything like that so that's what
actually settle this up and to do that
it actually uses node and to run grunt
because grunt is a a node package and
that's actually all we use note for is
just running the build process so we
don't actually use it for anything else
I looks like on another question there
was some confusion which actually
tripped me up when I first looked at it
too after looking we're looking at
Matt's code and build process yeah is
that you can run say grunt server and
that'll run a a local web server the
test we don't actually use that because
we also wanted to put it on the web and
on App Engine which doesn't support node
currently rich it's too bad so we
actually use grunt build to build the
entire application go through the entire
build process and that puts everything
in the dist folder and then you from
there run in the dist folder the local
App Engine instance using either the GUI
or dev appserver the Python script so
yeah in that case it will run on the
correct port and everything so don't use
grunt server use dev appserver the rest
of the build process is actually
relatively standard we use sass and so
we we do some some pre pre processing of
that to turn it into CSS we were
actually actually I just removed this we
were using compass because at the time I
was trying to get source maps to work
right oh yeah and sass at the time
didn't have support for actually
building source maps and it came maybe a
week or two after the course launched I
think it might maybe it's still not in
there but when I was building this it
wasn't quite there but they were like
yeah we're maybe a month away I was like
that's too late so I had to switch
everything over to compass but the
source maps didn't end up working anyway
is there a little brittle right now it
was basically a conflict between the
source map and autoprefixer which was
then changing lines because it was
adding than there prefixing so we
actually don't use compass aim where we
just use the sass tool to convert the
sass to CSS we use typical minifiers to
minify all of the JavaScript and
everything down to the minimum amount I
think we use uglify for that yep and
then power we use for actual client-side
dependency management if you don't if
you aren't aware of power it actually
tries to bring package management to the
client-side and it does a fantastic job
I'd highly recommend using power it's
it's a fantastic tool it makes adding
third-party libraries into your code
sane yeah it's it's it's hugely useful
library so I think those are the those
are the primary pieces that that
everything uses if I missed something
that you're still unclear on go ahead
and ask another quick answer we've still
got some time to do that but I think
those are the main pieces yeah perfect
thanks Jonathan so off topic are there
plans on making a Udacity course about
Dart angular Dart polymer one of the
remaining 58 so from javi oh yeah in
Spain so all of those would be awesome
they would all be great I think like I
said we don't have anything to announce
mm-hmm quite yet but we are very
actively looking at mm-hmm a building
out more of this curriculum and we're
actually meeting this week yeah so stay
tuned for more details front and all of
those in specific would be really
awesome I will I for one love polymer
it's probably not quite at a stage yet
it's early it's a little early but it's
it's coming really cool very quickly
sort of very excited about
right mm-hmm Oh Alden would be really
cool question from su how accurate is
geolocation in the average mobile device
but in a few meters centimeters I have
an idea for an app but I need to locate
features accurately so one of the things
that you get back so when you call the
geolocation API is su you get back the
lat/long mm-hmm and a third accuracy
mm-hmm so there's really no way when you
create an app you can't really know
who's using it and on what device
they're on and and also whether they're
using for example Wi-Fi so so the
geolocation effectively there's no way
to say give it to me from Wi-Fi or GPS
or anything like that there's a there's
a high accuracy mode from that you can
turn on and that's the first thing you
should be doing mm-hm turn that on it's
just a parameter that you pass in and
enable high accuracy you know don't
quote me on the exact wording but you
can turn it on to get the most accurate
view but there's no guarantee as to what
you're getting back because that depends
a lot on what people have turned on so
if they've turned on pretty much
everything there is and many devices
will ask you that yeah they'll say hey
do you want to add Wi-Fi mm-hmm so we
get an even better view if you've done
that you're gonna get a very accurate
like literally down to a few but it's
it's beat meters for sure but it's
there's 90 centimeters but not not it
always will be some meters but the
interesting thing is you get back the
accuracy as a parameter in meter so
that's basically a radius of like how
far like you could be away from so it
the API will give you back a sense of
how accurate this is going to be so it
could be something like well you're
within a mile at this location or you're
within meters from this location so
there isn't a way to say to guarantee a
certain accuracy but there is a way to
check
how accurate and then said to two
interactive user say well yeah you know
we we can't really do anything right now
you need to have a more accurate reading
yeah and so on so hopefully that helps
yeah and I don't think there's a way to
do centimeters right now unfortunately I
would enable a lot of really cool
possibilities in store beacons yeah yep
all right so can you go over to files so
Luke in Honolulu again can you go over
to files in the conference app and the
build process I think there's a bug in
the conference app running grunt server
this is what you were that's not good I
was early or not before opens the server
on port 9000 however the browser looks
for adjacent files on me dat what's
going on so yeah that's a note yeah so
that's if you run grunt server then it
will run on port 9000 right and if you
run apps or server then it'll run on
port 8080 just make sure that you're in
the after you run grunt build change
into the dist sub folder and run dev
appserver there or run the the App
Engine Goyo yeah either one will work
and that'll that should unless you've
got another App Engine instance or
another local server something running
run on port 8080 perfect okay so I think
let me double check that yep so we're at
the end of the questions for today yeah
so all of these office hours are
recorded as soon as we're done here live
they were the recording will be
available at the same URL so you can
definitely check it out if you if you
missed it next week will be our final
episode you can ask questions on the
the Dory is already open you can go not
ask her way out you can ask questions
about any of the the lessons really
never knock that originally we thought
well just the final three lessons but
feel free to ask anything Chris we'll be
back
mm-hmm and yeah yeah you shouldn't ping
him and ask him when he's gonna get back
from Maui and wise you know what's
happened it's bending time there instead
of with us
sipping mai-tais on the beach yeah sure
so yeah so we'll be back next week the
you can check it out on Google
developers live developers.google.com
slash live slash chrome that's where
you'll find all of the different
episodes on Google developers live that
we're putting on including next week's 9
o'clock same time we'll be back and in
the meantime hopefully you're having
good hope I hope you have a good week
and yeah see you talk to you next week
yeah bye guys bye